[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous parlais d'un petit
programme qui peut vraiment vous sauver
la vie pour votre smartphone pour
récupérer des données pour récupérer des
photos des messages des textes et email
pour faire migrer les données d'un
smartphone un autre pour pas mal de
choses mais juste avant je vous montre
un truc trop cool j'ai reçu un colis et
je sais que ça va vous plaire regardez
ce qui est arrivé aujourd'hui je sais
que ça c'est un truc ça fait longtemps
que j'ai envie de vous en parler avec
trop cool regardez-moi ça regardez moi
ça alors ici nous avons tout premier
samsung galaxy place is plus j'ai testé
ya pas longtemps le 6 mai pas une assise
plus là ça va être l'occasion
c'est génial poids deuxième point et pas
des moindres regardez ce qu'on a ici
galaxie watch ça aussi c'est vraiment un
truc génial la galaxie au h
je vous en ai parlé il ya pas très
longtemps lors de la présentation du
galaxy note 9
je suis super content de l'avoir ici
comme je vous le dis les mondes
connectés on va beaucoup parler la
galaxie watch je vais l'attesté il ya
aussi la tique watch pro que je vais
tester qui est juste là il y en a plein
d'autres
il ya là me band 3 qui est là il y en
aura pas d'autre donc ça c'est aussi top
génial merci samsung et dernier point et
là franchement je crois que ça va
envoyer du bois
attendez attendez n'emballe pas les
choses à moitié du côté de chez samsung
regardez-moi sa galaxy tab s4 ça c'est
juste de la bombe atomique c'est la
nouvelle tablette de samsung écran super
amoled et spain 64 giga enfin bref un
truc de fou furieux
donc un grand merci à samsung de m'avoir
envoyé toutes ces nouveautés qu'on va
pouvoir tester à leurs nouveautés le
assise plus c'est pas forcément la
nouveauté du moment
mais j'avais vraiment envie de le tester
mais surtout petit bijou technologique
la galaxie watch les mondes collective a
beaucoup en parler ce cas pas mal de
choses qui arrivent
on a eu la présentation est fière d'eux
de la pelouse chiris 4 pour le coup les
mondes connectés topissime est cette
fameuse thales 4 je suis trop heureux
voilà voilà pour cette courte intro
maintenant on va parler des
problématiques de sauvegarde de
smartphones de transfert d'un faux entre
smartphones c'est une vidéo partenariat
avec wonder cher abonde dans ce sens l'a
contacté en me disant hey monsieur dreux
on a une solution qui est super cool
pour tous les possesseurs de smartphones
parce qu'à un moment ou un autre on
rencontre tous des problèmes avec nos
smartphones très clairement je crois que
je sais pas si vous savez vous est pas
arrivé mais moi ça m'est arrivé des
grosses galères avec mes smartphones ce
bon alors on parle bien évidemment pas
uniquement de casser de smartphones qui
se brisent la affectivement un logiciel
plus globalement passé à grand chose
pour vous mais typiquement un petit
smartphone dont vous avez des problèmes
pour récupérer des données l'atypique
manger toutes les données toutes les
photos de la première année de naissance
de mon fils que j'ai pas pu récupérer
donc beaucoup ça peut franchement
m'aider voilà donc ça c'est vrai que
c'est un outil qui est vraiment bien
c'est un espèce de couteau suisse si
vous voulez dr von parce que ça vous
permet de faire plein de choses en un
seul et même logiciel
je vous montre comment ça marche il ya
pas mal de fonctionnalités différentes
vous pouvez transférer des données entre
votre téléphone et votre ordinateur
récupérer les données de votre téléphone
ça pour moi c'est un des points les plus
importants et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai vraiment voulu vous
montrer ce logiciel vous pouvez copier
des données d'un téléphone à l'autre
sauvegarder restaurer bon ça c'est un
grand classique réparer votre système
ios croyez moi que ça peut être vraiment
intéressant effacé données de votre
téléphone bon pourquoi pas ça c'est une
solution plus est retirée l'écran de
verrouillage de votre téléphone pour
faire un test j'ai ici mon smartphone
j'ai mon câble je vais tout branché pour
regarder l'option récupérer elle les
données de votre téléphone
on voit effectivement qu'on est dans mon
iphone appareils connectés février
sélectionner le type de données que vous
souhaitez récupérer contact appel pièces
jointes viber et pièces jointes j'en ai
pas whatsapp ça ne m'intéresse pas enfin
pourquoi pas à la limite on va tout
essayer données présentes sur l'appareil
ok on va lancer la numérisation et on va
voir ce que ça donne est ce que il va
avoir accès à des choses que j'ai
complètement oublié
classé un peu confidentiel peut-être à
voir on va voir
c'est juste complètement ouf tout ce que
ça va récupérer qu'à l'image il ya même
des photos je ne sais même pas d'où
elles sortent
il ya des souvenirs de voyage à l'époque
était sur what's app
il ya des trucs j'ai l'impression de
facebook il ya des choses c'est
incroyable toutes les données qu'il ya
là dedans sont complètement hallucinante
j'ai re découvre des photos géantes font
que j'avais même plus dans mon téléphone
quand coup je dois reconnaître que pour
récupérer de la data l'outil est
vraiment vraiment impressionnant là vous
avez tout est classé vie privée et
messages contacts calendriers appareil
photo ou être sa pièce jointoyées
effectivement tout un mélange de ce que
j'ai dans mon smartphone c'est juste
dingue
lorsque vous allez récupérer des données
dans votre smartphone depuis votre
ordinateur vous choisissez celles que
vous voulez récupérer c'est que vous
voulez apporter et points qui suit pas
l'important vous n'allez pas du tout
perdre les autres elles ne vont pas être
écrasé elle reste dans votre smartphone
et pour le coup vous êtes plutôt
tranquille autre point c'est sympa vous
avez la possibilité de télécharger tout
le contenu de votre iphone ça vous
permet de faire une sauvegarde c'est une
version alternative à ce que vous avez
sur itunes aujourd'hui ou alors sur
l'icloud
c'est pas mal on peut le faire et bien
évidemment avec ios mais également avec
android vous avez aussi une option qui
est assez intéressante c'est la
réparation si vous êtes par exemple
bloqué sur le logo apple que vous avez
une boucle du mode de récupération en
écran noir
vous avez la possibilité de tout des
billets avec ça c'est une option qui est
plutôt pas mal et qui à mon avis pourra
sauver la vie à plus d'une personne
voilà pour ce qui j'espère que ça vous
aura aidé alors un vide est
effectivement là c'est de vous présenter
un outil que je crois en tout cas moi
pertinent parce qu'il peut vous aider
vraiment lorsque vous allez rencontrer
des problèmes
vous n'allez pas forcément en avoir
besoin tout le temps parce que c'est
vrai qu on a globalement je l'espère en
tout cas pour vous pas tout le temps des
problèmes avec vos smartphones mais
lorsque vous en rencontrez vous êtes
bien content de pouvoir trouver des
outils un petit peu couteau suisse pour
vous sortir de la panade
voilà merci un soyez sages vous invite
une fois de plus à me laisser vos
commentaire directement baky surtout
surtout et surtout restez connectés
parce que regarder tout ce qui arrive
derrière moi c'est juste out de la folie
en ce moment on a la galaxy tab est
quatre à six plus à tester galaxie watch
tic watch pro on a testé il ya pas très
longtemps lepoko phone geste ne
reparlera
l'ami band 3 qui est la leur au nord
playes ya plein d'autres trucs qui
arrive
donc je vous invite à faire une seule
chose c'est à vous abonner et à rester
connectés
[Musique]